midi info avec Alec Castonguay
[Musique]
bonjour tout le monde j'ai le plaisir de
vous annoncer que la campagne électorale
va être déclenchée officiellement le 28
août prochain je vais mettre François
Legault au défi sur l'économie
l'économie va être la question de l'urne
on a besoin d'avoir le plus de députés
écologistes possibles à l'Assemblée
nationale et chaque député qu'on ajoute
c'est de la pression qu'on met pour que
le Québec enfin prennent le virage
nécessaire dans la lutte au changement
climatique
pour moi c'est comme une évidence reste
à décider ce que c'est un pont ou un
tunnel nous on souhaite un tunnel le
système public est pas capable de vous
offrir un service dans des délais
raisonnables à ce moment-là vous avez
droit d'aller dans le système privé si
on décidait nous-mêmes de nos budgets
qu'on prenait nos propres décisions
comme québécoise québécois on serait pas
pris à quémander comme toutes les
provinces canadiennes des sommes aussi
majeurs que 6 milliards de dollars la
seule solution à ça c'est l'indépendance
du Québec
rebonjour bienvenue à notre émission
spéciale sur les élections québécoises
2022 diffusée en direct du plateau au W
sur la mezzanine de la nouvelle Maison
de Radio-Canada nous passerons la
prochaine heure à répondre à vos
questions avec nos invités évidemment je
me suis préparé quelques questions de
mon cru quand même à moi aussi mais avec
nos invités Marie-Hélène Tremblay qui
est analyste politique car Radio-Canada
bonjour Marie-Hélène bonjour
Alexine l'actualité et au Toronto Star
bonjour Chantal bonjour Alex je le sais
chroniqueur politique à La Presse et
Radio-Canada bonjour Michel et Philippe
j'ai Fournier créateur des sites Québec
125 338 Canada spécialiste des sondages
des projections de siège bonjour
Philippe bonjour Alex alors on a eu
beaucoup de questions de nos auditeurs
il y en a nous-mêmes choisi mais on veut
faire d'abord on va faire on va y aller
en trois temps on va faire un peu un
bilan de la campagne ensuite parler du
contenu des promesses des engagements on
va terminer avec les choses à surveiller
l'impact que ça peut avoir lundi sur les
différents partis Marie-Hélène on passer
toute la campagne électorale vous et moi
ensemble chaque journée vous avez scruté
les points de presse les itinéraires des
différents chefs les promesses en détail
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que vous
avez retenu sur le déroulement sur la
dynamique de la campagne mais disons que
5S 5 parties ça représentait un certain
nombre j'ai calculé environ une centaine
de points de presse une centaine de
mails et de presse alors faites le
compte il y en a eu beaucoup il y en a
eu de toutes sortes aussi du côté de la
coalition à venir Québec qui avait
pourtant choisi un slogan continuons
mais parfois on pouvait se demander si
François Legault avait réellement envie
de continuer d'avoir un deuxième mandat
parce que justement ça pas été toujours
facile pour lui des débats difficiles du
côté du Parti libéral on le souvent dit
une campagne difficile pour dominer
Anglade du début à la fin véritablement
Québec solidaire portant une bonne
lancée un déclenchement qui a quand même
été
frappant marquant pour la troupe de
Québec solidaire mais ça s'est vite
essoufflé un bon premier débat mais
ensuite on dirait qu'on a perdu un peu
le momentum du côté de Québec solidaire
dans le cas du Parti québécois bien Paul
Saint-Pierre plat Mondon s'est fait
connaître c'est essentiellement ce à
quoi a servi le début de sa campagne a
eu de bons débats s'en est tenu à son
plan de match et leur a respecté du
début à la fin enfin le parti de
conservateur j'ai envie de dire c'est un
peu la campagne de l'autoroute 20 entre
Québec et Montréal essentiellement la
région de Québec une campagne justement
où il a beaucoup de surfés irréduum sur
le mécontentement des électeurs est-ce
que ça lui aura permis justement de
faire le plein on a senti un certain
moment un essoufflement et que là on
avait atteint justement le maximum qu'il
pouvait aller chercher une campagne
l'autoroute ça m'a ça me fait penser à
François Legault 2012 il y avait fait
aussi pas mal une campagne comme ça de
la grande région de Québec aller
chercher les appuis pour son nouveau
parti je rappelle diffuser en direct sur
Facebook sur les pages de Radio-Canada
information également sur ici première
si vous avez des questions à poser à nos
panélistes n'hésitez pas à écrivez-nous
dans les commentaires on a des lecteurs
assidus des recherches qui regardent ça
qui vont pouvoir me les transmettre
évidemment si ça s'insère bien dans la
conversation n'hésitez pas Michel vous
allez couvert pas mal de campagne
électorales en quoi celle-ci est
peut-être différent des autres je pense
pas que je me souvienne d'une campagne
électorale où les mouvements auront
jamais dépassé la marge d'erreur des
sondages on va se retrouver avec
probablement lundi soir pourcentage de
vote assez similaire au premier sondage
de la campagne c'est dû au fait qu'il y
a quatre parties d'opposition c'est dû
au fait aussi qu'il y a pas eu
d'événements majeurs qui souvent
viennent bouleverser une campagne on n'a
pas eu cette fois-ci cette campagne là
qui est partie sur le thème de protéger
les gens sur l'inflation qui est très
rapidement sur autre chose et la fin on
a eu plus des campagnes de personnalité
des campagnes d'idées
donc on va se retrouver avec la
difficulté qu'on avait prévu au départ
c'est-à-dire 5 parties quatre parties
d'opposition qui se à peu près au coude
puis à partir qui à cause du mode de
scrutin risque de se retrouver avec
beaucoup plus de sièges qu'il a de fois
Chantal comment vous qualifiez cette
campagne électorale
il y a deux sortes de campagne il y a
des campagnes électorales qui sont des
campagnes de changement d'autres qui
sont des campagnes de continuité et on
va revenir au langage corporel de
monsieur Legault c'est sûr mais on est
plus et pour la première fois depuis
2008 on serait plus dans une campagne de
continuité c'est à dire que après 2008
c'est jean-charrey qui remporte sa
majorité
puis après ça on essaye trois parties un
après l'autre un seul mandat pour
Pauline pour Philippe Couillard puis
François Legault arrive alors on
reviendrait ce qui était une habitude
l'habitude du deuxième mandat ça donne
toujours des campagnes un petit peu
moins mouvementée ce que c'est différent
deux autres grosses différences j'ai
jamais vu de campagne ou cinq parties
étaient couvertes de façon aussi
paritaire et j'inclus le fédéral
là-dedans c'est pas vrai qu'on couvre le
Parti vert comme on a couvert le Parti
conservateur au Québec ou concours le
bloc à l'extérieur du Québec comme on a
couvert de particulier et ça change la
dynamique c'est probablement un avantage
pour François Legault parce que quatre
oppositions qui sont couverts également
ça n'a plus difficile de coaliser
l'opposition c'est probablement bon
aussi pour les quatre parce que à cause
de la pandémie François Legault avait
occupé tellement l'espace que ces
chefs-là avaient pas vraiment eu la
chance de se faire connaître la dernière
différence c'est frappante cette semaine
je vais pas vous j'ai jamais couvert un
gagnant qui avait autant l'air d'un
mauvais gagnant qui était de si mauvaise
humeur alors qui clairement va remporter
son pari je reçois l'entrevue mercredi
mais non j'ai beaucoup de plaisir tout
va bien mais j'ai failli lui dire ben
peut-être que votre visage devrait en
témoigner puisque c'est pas ça semble
pas toujours le cas effectivement
d'autre part
Philippe j'ai fourni vous êtes
spécialiste vous avez regardé toutes les
sondages de tension de vote est-ce
qu'effectivement on assiste à une
stabilité comme on comme Michel le
disait une stabilité comme on a rarement
vu depuis longtemps au Québec comme
chantant le dit trois élections
consécutives trois gagnants consécutifs
j'ai fait mes recherches au Canada c'est
vraiment pas arrivé souvent ça j'ai vu
le libéral Peterson ensuite Bob Ray et
Michaelis Ontario je n'ai pas trouvé
d'autres au Canada de trois élections
consécutives et trois gagnants et là on
regarde les chiffres la CAC en moyenne
dans mon modèle est à 39% des intentions
de vote donc c'est à peu près le même
niveau que 2018 mais l'opposition
complètement divisée et comme Michel Le
mentionné si on regarde les premiers
sondages de la campagne bon le PQ a
peut-être monté d'une poignée de points
particulières elle a peut-être descendu
de 18 à 16 mais c'est on reste dans les
mêmes zones et donc on a une stabilité
qui on va voir ça perdure jusque dans
l'une lundi on attend les derniers
sondages en fin de semaine mais pour
l'instant ça n'a vraiment pas beaucoup
bougé j'entends est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'on a fait une campagne électorale
pourrie
non les campagnes inextérieures servent
toujours à quelque chose dans ce cas-ci
je pense que beaucoup de de lecteurs
mais même de kakis et demande du caucus
de la coalition à venir Québec qui ont
regardé monsieur Lego un peu
méconnaissable par rapport au personnage
qu'assemblent la pandémie et qui se sont
dit va falloir qu'on commence à penser à
notre avenir sans ce chef-là dans les
quatre prochaines années et ça va
changer la dynamique à l'intérieur du
gouvernement la montée entre guillemets
du Parti conservateur dépendant des
résultats pourraient aussi changer la
conversation à l'intérieur de la
coalition à venir Québec c'est à dire si
on commence à percevoir qu'il y a
vraiment quelque chose de menaçant à
droite c'est bon à influencer les débats
et j'ai l'impression que solidaire c'est
un échec pour Québec solidaire où on est
en fin de course dans la mesure où le
palier de Québec solidaire c'était se
détacher du plateau d'opposition pour
devenir l'opposition officielle à partir
des débats je dirais à partir de
des projets fiscaux qui sont devenus
attaquement mais c'est vrai que toute la
question de la fiscalité collée
complètement mais ça a enlevé les
langues et on finit la campagne ils sont
loin de 4 alors ces matières à réflexion
on peut argumenter tant qu'on voudra sur
le projet de Québec solidaire mais ça
n'a pas passé la rampe Michel est-ce que
il y a des moments particuliers de cette
campagne qui vous ont marqué moi je
pense que c'est de la campagne ou des
gens connus un moment donné quelque
chose qui a fait qui a eu un arrêt de
croissance des gens qui étaient sur une
lancée j'entends à parler de la taxe
orange oui pour le pour Québec c'est le
dire ça a été un véritable problème et
surtout que ça avait l'air d'une
taxidéologique l'impôt sur la fortune ça
fait socialiste français ça c'est pas
dans nos habitudes à nous et ils l'ont
défendu jusqu'à la dernière seconde sans
admettre que il y avait peut-être on
peut peut-être considérer que quelqu'un
qui a acheté un Tripi avec ses 30 ans
sur la malheureusement et millionnaire
mais c'est pas ça lui donne pas être un
vide millionnaire monsieur drem était
sur une belle lancée quand l'affaire de
ces impôts impayés sont arrivés étaient
arrivés
complètement les deux autres ont eu je
parle des parties de l'opposition
madame anglaise ça n'a jamais décollé et
c'est ça qui est le problème c'est que
elle est comme rester sur les blocs de
départ le PQ c'est un peu l'inverse
c'est que plus on a découvert peu
saint-pierre-la-montrond donc plus il
devait sympathique mais on n'a pas
beaucoup parlé de ces propositions non
plus mais monsieur Legault
j'ai un ami qui était dans plusieurs
cabinets qui motive il vieillit vite
puis vieille mal et le problème qui va
avoir Chantal il a fait allusion c'est
que le lendemain de l'élection c'est le
début de quand est-ce qu'il m'a et
dans un parti qui le lui-même créé c'est
un peu la situation d'un éléphant au
Parti québécois à la fin là c'est plus
difficile de mettre le bosse dehors
quand il crée une partie mais en même
temps il y a pas mal de monde qui
commence à dire qui vont commencé à dire
à moins qu'il se que tout revienne au
bon fixe après l'élection ce qui est pas
certain qui va dire
l'immigration a quand même beaucoup
Michel retenu l'attention du côté de la
coalition Québec ont fini les deux
dernières semaines un peu empêtrés dans
différentes déclarations ça pas été
simple sur cette question là ça peut
être simple et ça ressemble bien
franchement un peu à des campagnes de
peur quand on dit si on a plus que
quelques 50 000 immigrants par année
c'est suicidaire pour la nation
québécoise on peut plus avoir de
discussions
alors qu'est-ce que vous voulez le
président de la Chambre de commerce dit
moi j'ai j'ai un autre chiffre puis j'ai
une autre façon de voir ça peut-être
qu'on peut discuter de ça c'est à dire
non non c'est celui-ci là c'est de faire
là on peut plus avoir de discussion je
pense que là-dessus ils ont poussé le
bouchon un petit peu trop fort on a une
question d'un de nos auditeurs Robert
sans quartiers Michel justement sur
l'immigration et je vous la lis est-ce
qu'il vous est venu à l'idée que la
controverse sur l'immigration quand on
parle de ça provoqué par François
Legault visait peut-être à faire sortir
son vote
il y a toujours dans des dossiers comme
ceux-là la possibilité je ne dis pas que
c'est volontairement ce qu'ils ont fait
mais la possibilité là de dire voici ce
qui est genre pense tout bas mais ne
disent pas tout haut on va au moins
envoyer le l'appel du pied que c'est ça
qu'on passe nous autres aussi on peut
pas enlever cette possibilité là en même
temps on peut pas consommer les reins et
des câbles savoir quel est le sentiment
profond cela dit la coalition va venir
Québec partait avec une longueur
d'avance et dans ses objectifs
qualitatifs pas quantitatif parce qu'ils
avaient pas besoin de s'en soucier
tellement il y avait
occupé plus de terrain sur l'île de
Montréal
et essayez important c'est pas c'est pas
simple d'avoir un gouvernement et je
pense que monsieur Legault serait
d'accord avec ce concepteur d'avoir un
gouvernement qui le reste du Québec est
pas Montréal mais
l'épisode sur l'immigration ça va aussi
faire sortir du vote qui risque de faire
que ces gains là espéré par la coalition
à venir Québec pourquoi ce matériel
c'est parce que on les entend là avec
raison beaucoup
d'électeurs qui disent moi je parle
français je suis venu ici à 30 ans mes
enfants sont allés à l'école en français
et là le ministre l'immigration dit non
seulement que je parle pas français mais
que je travaille pas
il faut le faire on a eu une question
d'ailleurs de nous dire Robert Leblanc
de Longueuil je la pose à Marie-Hélène
sa question était on n'a pas soulevé
l'hypothèse du suicide politique comme
certains l'ont fait dans le passé en
volant des gants ou un veston je pense
qu'on fait référence à Claude Charron en
janvier 1982 chez iTunes ceux qui se
rappelle de cet événement là
le monsieur Leblanc nous dit une
décision consciente ou inconsciente
parle de Jean Boulet pour sortir du
système il me semble que c'est trop gros
trop grave comme déclaration pour ne pas
évoquer une hypothèse de la sorte
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez monsieur
Leblanc a raison quand il dit que c'est
une déclaration justement qui est grave
surtout qu'elle n'est pas comme le
disait Chantal le reflet de la réalité
reste que Monsieur boulet accordé
quelques entrevues hier c'est confondu
en excuse n'empêche la question
justement du suicide politique a pas été
nécessairement abordé dans ces
entrevues-là
comme on dit
fait très peu d'erreurs là durant son
mandat bon évidemment François Legault a
été clair là-dessus et ça le disqualifie
comme ministre de l'Environnement
n'empêche avoir justement si
effectivement François Legault fait
davantage le plein de députés le lundi
soir est-ce que ça lui garantit pour
autant une place sur le Conseil des
ministres
avoir mais n'empêche qu'effectivement
jean-boulé c'est assurément tiré dans le
pied avec cette déclaration là
d'ailleurs on a une question de Johanne
Meyrin qui demande quel est le poids
réel des gaffes de certains candidats
bénévoles on voit le contrats des
déclarations controversées dans le passé
il y en a eu chez des candidats
conservateurs je fais des candidats même
encore aujourd'hui qui ressortent est-ce
que ça pèse Chantal dans les campagnes
électorales sur ce type de gaffe là ça
dépend combien il y en a et de quelle
partie il est question c'est à dire que
par exemple les Québec solidaire
accumulé ce genre de candidats mais un
parti moins établi qui a une enfilade de
ce genre de candidats ce serait plus le
cas par exemple du Parti conservateur du
Québec ça va faire que les électeurs
vont acheter ils sont pas prêts quand on
couvert à l'époque le Parti réformiste
qui tentait de s'imposer à l'extérieur
des prairies et on sortait
systématiquement non enfilade de
candidats qui disait à peu près
n'importe quoi c'est sûr qu'en Ontario
les électeurs regardent de ça ils disent
la phrase anglaise
on n'est pas prêt pour
mais autrement un incident de parcours
ici et là non je pense que la plupart
des électeurs se disent ça arrive qu'on
se plante pas la même chose quand c'est
le Ministre l'immigration évidemment qui
devrait normalement
Philippe question de Lauréline Chautard
qui parle vous dit tout à l'heure les
sondages ont pas bougé beaucoup
effectivement elle dit
personne n'avait venu venir l'élection à
Sherbrooke ou à rouen-noranda de Québec
solidaire en 2018 est-ce que même si ça
ne bouge pas sur le point le plan
national ça veut pas dire qu'en le fond
qu'on est capable de bel et bien savoir
où il va y avoir des surprises est-ce
qu'on peut encore se fier au sondage
c'est sûr que je vais avoir un bémol
là-dessus on avait vu la montée de
Québec on avait pas vu la victoire on
avait vu que c'était tout à fait
plausible et c'est un peu la même chose
présentement Québec solidaire et
compétitif dans peut-être 14 ou 15 c'est
conscription il ne va pas toutes les
gagner mais une bonne soirée une bonne
sortie de votre très régionalisée
peut-être que ça pourrait être 14e siège
mais la régionalisation du vote en effet
écoutez si on regarde les projections
actuelles et là bien sûr il y a encore
une marge d'erreur là-dedans on s'entend
mais la carte pourrait gagner deux
sièges sur 27 à Montréal et en gagner 90
sur 98 hors de Montréal et là c'est
vraiment un des balancements importants
deux sièges sur 27 c'est le même
résultat pour la CAQ à Montréal mais 90
sur 98 c'est bien plus élevé que 2018 et
on voit on a eu
[Musique]
que parler d'avenir c'est une jolie
histoire que celle du PQ mais le film ne
colle plus vraiment la réalité qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez
une partie des problèmes du Parti
québécois est effectivement l'espèce de
passéisme que que
mon dos essaie de ne pas incarner mais
une fois de temps en temps il est obligé
de revenir à l'argumentaire traditionnel
du PQ on peut pas être le PQ sans dire
un certain nombre de choses
le problème de Québec solidaire est un
peu l'inverse c'est que oui ils sont
souvenais mais c'est pas la clé de leur
programme la monnaie Québec et le
pourquoi qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent faire
ils sont ils sont un peu verts ils sont
un peu souvenais ce qui sont un peu
gaucher c'est quoi l'identité réelle il
y a pas une question la question de
l'urne que Québec pourrait poser pour
être porté alors c'est pas
l'environnement votre avis parce qu'on a
quand même beaucoup plus verts de de
tous mais le PQ un très bon programme en
environnement aussi au niveau des bas
les deux les deux se féliciter
mutuellement alors
c'est c'est ça le problème un peu de
QS puis d'un autre côté le problème du
PQ c'est oui on est dans un
malgré tout malgré un jeune chef dans un
côté assez penséiste on va faire plus de
loi 101
c'est les solutions d'hier on va les
reprendre sont encore bonnes il y a une
raison pour ça après le référendum de 95
et contre toute attente au sein du
québécois ce qu'on a vu c'est que la
clientèle souverainiste celle qui
voulait en effet un homme et qui voulait
voter oui vieillisser et que les
générations les nouvelles tranches
d'électeurs suivaient pas à un moment
donné Bernard Landry disait les
personnes âgées sont fédéralistes et
elles s'en vont toutes
parce que les jeunes sont
automatiquement souverainetés
la génération des baby-boomers mais que
dans les autres tranches d'âge d'un
sondage et d'une année à l'autre on a vu
l'appui à la souveraineté donc si le PQ
est en train de se battre pour sa survie
ça a du bon sens parler du passé parce
qu'il s'adresse à des gens qui étaient
là et qui sont sa meilleure clientèle
puis en plus quand l'avantage d'aller
voter plus acidument que les tranches
les plus jeunes les derniers publicités
du PQ c'est revenir à la maison
littéralement alors ça s'adresse pas aux
bébés ça s'adresse aux bébés ça
s'adresse pas à un plus jeune ça parlons
un peu de contenu des plateformes
électorales on a eu plusieurs questions
Marylène bon il y a eu énormément de
proposition parler tout à l'heure de
cinq parties ça fait énormément de
choses à discuter est-ce qu'il y a des
des points précis des choses qu'on
devrait retenir de certaines
propositions les partis politiques en
fait la première semaine l'ensemble des
parties là c'est c'était ça se disputer
les baisses d'impôts les chèques disons
pour justement contrer la flambée de
l'inflation on avait même nous la
difficulté à s'y retrouver même la même
journée François Legault et Dominique
Anglade ont fait pour ainsi dire la même
proposition en voulant donner deux en
donner 2000 dollars aux personnes âgées
de plus de 70 ans alors si nous on avait
du mal à s'y retrouver je présume que
c'était la même chose aussi pour les
électeurs surtout en début de campagne
parce que les gens sont moins attentifs
et on le dit une campagne à l'automne
après la fête du travail les gens
commencent justement s'intéresser
davantage à la campagne électorale il y
a quand même des choses aussi dont on a
très très peu parlé on a parlé
évidemment d'immigration on a parlé
abondamment du
déclaration de François Legault en
disant que les gens de Montréal
regardaient les gens de Québec de haut
alors ça aussi ça avait fait quand même
pas mal de bruit mais on a très très peu
parlé d'éducation alors que François
Legault se tarde à dire que s'il est en
politique c'est justement pour la cause
de l'éducation et on l'a vu on a été en
pleine rentrée scolaire manque encore
des enseignants du personnel spécialisé
le transport scolaire est difficile et
on a très peu parlé en bout de piste de
l'éducation durant la campagne Michel
Chantal j'ai des engagements qui vous
ont marqué davantage Michel j'ai pas
vraiment d'engagement qui ont plaisir
ont réussi à faire changer la campagne
il y a des bonnes idées il y a des
choses qui sont intéressantes je parlais
des
programmes environnementaux et du PQ et
de Québec solidaire il y a des choses
là-dedans qui sont intéressantes qui
devraient être regardés mais j'ai pas vu
un engagement qui a réussi à
enflammer la campagne à l'inverse
le principal problème de Madame Anglade
ça a été précisément d'avoir des
engagements qui touchaient pas et qui
touchaient pas les gens c'est beau
l'histoire de l'hydrogène vert mais
c'est un carburant qu'on va peut-être
vendre aux Allemands dans 20-30 ans on
va pas rendu là et les gens sont pas
reconnus là-dedans et ça a eu l'air d'un
programme avec qui venait d'en haut qui
arrivait du pain
une promesse qui reste il faut qu'elle
soit différente de l'offre d'à peu près
tout ce qui se présente autour donc le
pqs sont neutralisés mutuellement sur la
question climatique et la base des
millions de la première semaine le
premier résultat ça a été de neutraliser
l'enjeu de l'inflation et de comment on
y répond et la deuxième condition de
cette promesse qui reste c'est aussi
qu'elle ne devienne pas la taxe orange
dans cette campagne ciste c'est-à-dire
quelque chose qui fait reculer la
formation ou qui lui fait faire du sur
place la dernière fois qu'on en avait
une promesse comme ça
oser mais qui a quand même marché c'est
Justin Trudeau qui promet de faire des
déficits et la plupart d'entre nous qui
étaient là
mais au début on s'est dit qu'elle
scénario
dangereux oui une partie de mes rêves va
payer une facture je pense quand même
sur un dossier troisième lien dont on a
beaucoup parlé même si on est à Montréal
on va en reparler il y a une occasion
manquée pour la coalition à venir Québec
c'est à dire que la majorité des gens
qui soient à Montréal ou ailleurs
c'était pas fait une tête sur le
troisième lien
et c'était une belle occasion pour la
carte 14 parler d'expliquer son projet
et sa démarche de façon à ce que des
gens qui sont pas
engagés d'un côté finalement peut-être
pas une si mauvaise affaire ou des bons
arguments et c'est le contraire qui
s'est passé si vous étiez pas vendu à
l'idée du troisième lien que vous avez
regardé la campagne de la coalition à
venir Québec vous le laisses
certainement pas plus aujourd'hui après
vous avez peut-être dire qu'il y a pas
d'études que quoi qu'elle dise on va le
faire pareil que la population va
baisser mais non c'est pas grave parce
qu'ils vont arriver comme
et ça c'est une occasion gratter qui va
revenir en thé je crois le gouvernement
qui acquise s'il est reconduit la
semaine prochaine Marie là dans une
question de qui vient de Facebook de
nous d'une de nos auditrices Marie
meunier comment interprétez-vous le fait
que les chefs ont été pas mal seul sur
scène nous n'avons pas vu beaucoup de
personnalités autour des chefs notamment
au parti libérales pour appuyer par
exemple Dominique Anglade c'est vrai que
le numéro ont été absents on le disait
aussi au niveau de l'organisation
libérale on a vraiment l'impression que
les disons les organisateurs libéraux
sont restés à la maison il n'était pas
là
il y a eu bien sûr Carlos l'État ou qui
était là ceux qui quittent justement
parce que quand même 13 des 27 députés
libéraux qui ont quitté cette élection
aussi mais c'est vrai que les autres n'y
étaient pas on pourrait dire en fait il
y a pas de Saint-Pierre plat Mondon
quand même qui a réussi à ramener et on
a pu lire et entendre certains vieux
pékistes justement qui ont repris le
service ça fait campagne avec François
Gendron notamment Louise Beaudoin qui a
écrit aussi du côté de Québec solidaire
Françoise David mais très peu et
vraiment il y a pas eu d'artistes non
plus beaucoup qui se sont affichés avec
les chefs notamment c'est souvent le cas
pour les parties souverainistes on a vu
Daniel Boucher en Gaspésie mais c'est à
tout alors effectivement il y a eu une
absence de vedette qu'elle soit
politique ou qu'elle soit sur le milieu
du milieu artistique Philippe est-ce que
le dans les on regarde dans les
projections sièges est-ce que le
candidat ça notoriété à un impact est-ce
qu'on peut aller chercher une
circonscription parce qu'on est un
candidat vedette ou la campagne
nationale écrase tellement tout que ça
peut impact la réponse à ça
est bonne c'est très rare dans le sens
que il y a eu des sondages là-dessus à
répétition on voit encore environ 10 à
15% des électeurs disent voter pour un
candidat avant de partir le chef mais il
reste que 85% ils vont dire le parti le
chef bien sûr dans certaines
circonscriptions on regarde dans le cas
du PQ Veronique Yvon Sylvain Gaudreault
Rimouski veut dire qu'il y avait des
candidats importants locaux mais ce sont
des exceptions sur 125 circonscriptions
il va peut-être n'avoir une dizaine de
ce code de candidats qui peuvent
vraiment faire une différence à un seul
alors oui les campagnes locales sont
importantes mais dans une élection comme
la nôtre présentement c'est pas la
différence entre la victoire et la
défaite oui Michel ce qu'on a pas vu
cette année qu'on voyait toujours
c'était le parti qui très tôt dans la
campagne présentait son équipe
économique et désignait pratiquement son
ministre des Finances à part le Québec
et bien sûr tout ça dans très clair
clairement dans sa brochette de
candidats personne s'est soucier de
faire ça souvenez-vous monsieur Charrey
faisait ça là littéralement au début de
chaque campagne voici mon équipe
économique voici qui est mon ministre
des Finances et aucun des partis
d'opposition est allé là et je pense pas
qu'il y a quelqu'un qui se démarque dans
un parti d'opposition assez évident que
lui va être ministre des Finances ça
c'est ça prouve qu'on malgré tout ce
qu'on a dit sur la récession si on est
l'inflation et tout ça ça peut être une
campagne économique ce qui est quand
même assez assez nouveau mais j'ai
l'impression moi que si les parties ont
pas fait ça c'est parce que l'équipe au
finance et à la santé de monsieur
Legault à l'aide de toute façon faire
parler les gens qui allaient faire
monter sur l’estrade alors à ce
moment-là on dit
la comparaison
sortait beaucoup beaucoup et on sait pas
trop qui aurait été le ministre des
Finances des autres Johan Hamel qui pose
une question à Chantal et Michel sur la
fonderie de la fonderie est-ce que c'est
pas un peu facile de la part de François
Legault de dire ce sera la population de
décider est-ce que ce n'est pas le
devoir la responsabilité du gouvernement
de fixer les normes et de les faire
respecter afin de protéger la population
et l'environnement du Québec Michel
oui effectivement c'est le travail du
gouvernement de faire ça et monsieur
Legault essaie de
au football on dirait de faire la beauté
de dégagement en disant on va faire un
référendum on va et les gens décideront
s'ils veulent c'est beaux emplois
payants ou s'ils veulent de la qualité
de l'air c'est mettre des gens devant un
dilemme qui n'a pas de bon sens et c'est
c'est
refusé sa propre responsabilité
là-dedans cela dit ça fait partie aussi
du d'un autre
argumentaire de la cax c'est à dire
c'est pour Jean de Montréal d'aller
décider ça on l'a entendu beaucoup
entendu à fonderieur une sur le
troisième lien mais quand monsieur
Legault s'est bien répété ça encore hier
je suis pas sûr que c'est surtout que
c'est pas aux médecins qui travaillent
dans cette communauté là de dire que il
faudrait faire plus ça c'était
particulier dans la déclaration de
François Legault quand même
et oui il y a une certaine application
de les deux chips à dire ça parce que la
première page de la personne qui va être
premier ministre du Québec la semaine
prochaine dans cette fois-ci c'est de
pousser sur la compagnie pour qu'elle
arrive vraiment à une amélioration de sa
proposition ça c'est la première étape
c'est pas de faire la campagne de la
compagnie en disant ces beaux emplois
100000 dollars par année vous en aurez
plus c'est c'est comme si il était
devenu l'homme de la fonderie
fournit à quoi ressemble la course dans
One Noranda actuellement parce que
François degault était là cette semaine
Marylène nous disait à l'émission tout à
l'heure c'est quand même osé d'avoir été
faire un tour par là dans la dernière
semaine de la campagne
bien des gens présument qui va perdre
mais c'est pas si évident que ça c'est
cette course là écoutez emilyse laissant
rien avec causer les entreprises il y
avait des bons scores dans le Québec
solidaire avait causé la surprise en
2018 on savait qu'elle allait
compétitive mais elle s'est faux filée
en 2018 elle a eu 32% du vote et dans ce
temps-là 32% du vote ça veut dire que un
peu comme Denis Kader à la mairie après
201 tu dois essayer d'agrandir ta base
et et ce qu'on voit en région encore une
fois particulièrement la bitibi le vote
libéral et le vote piqué c'est
complètement effondré et donc est-ce que
ces gens-là vont aller vers Québec
solidaire peut-être une petite partie
mais la CAQ devrait considérer comme
favorite dans un avantage médicament à
ce point ci Marylène Tremblaye j'ai une
question qui nous provient de Twitter
qui demande faceco face au risque de
récession possible dont on parle
davantage est-ce qu'il y a un parti qui
vous semble mieux armé pour affronter
une potentielle crise économique est-ce
que dans le fond il y a un parti qui a
la carte financière économique à son
avantage de savoir cette auditeur en
fait la question ne s'est pas vraiment
posée parce que l'avant c'est elle du
côté de la coalition à venir Québec
qu'on dit que c'est la coalition à venir
Québec qui aura justement à s'occuper de
cette question là après le 3 octobre
mais on peut prendre la question
autrement parce que plusieurs parties
ont promis des baisses d'impôts c'est le
cas de la cape c'est le cas aussi du
parti libéral et du Parti conservateur
et alors quand on dit baisse d'impôts on
dit baisse également de la croissance du
côté du Parti conservateur on prévoit
aussi d'importantes compressions qui ont
aussi un effet sur la croissance de
l'économie Québec solidaire qui dit
qu'il va augmenter les taxes pour les
riches alors on a vu un peu aussi que ça
ça pourrait également avoir un effet sur
la façon dont l'économie du Québec va se
comporter bref
autre chose qui risque de faire
peut-être mal justement au Finances du
Québec si cette décision de piger dans
le fond des générations c'est quand la
coalition à venir Québec qui est allée
justement de cet engagement
[Musique]
parce que jamais on s'était commis dans
cette direction là du côté du ministre
Éric Girard et lorsqu'on a annoncé les
baisses d'impôts on a dit qu'on allait
réduire les virements au fond des
générations dans l'ordre de 40% du côté
de Québec solidaire on y met carré enfin
justement pour remplir les promesses
liées au
Plan Climat de ce parti-là alors bref il
reste que faudra voir comment l'économie
va se comporter c'est effectivement le
Québec entre en réception François
Legault disait il y a quelques jours qui
stimulait la possibilité à 50 % mais
maintenant alors comment va ensuite se
comporter les Finances du Québec ça ce
sera intéressant de surveiller ça on a
reçu beaucoup de questions sur le mode
de scrutin peut-être qu'on est une
émission d'intellectuel je sais pas où
je me suis pas battu dans les autobus je
vous le jure c'est pas moi qui a
provoqué ça
commençons par Philippe Jean question
qui vous est adressée par Dominique
Gravel je vous la CAQ semble casser du
dos sur le sucre sur le sucre quand
c'est du sucre sur le dos et verser mes
phrases la carte semble casser du sucre
sur le dos de Montréal parce qu'elle n'a
pas besoin des montréalers pour
l'élection de 2022 est-ce que les choses
seraient différentes si on avait un
scrutin proportionnel pourrait-elle se
permettre autant de se passer de ces
votes c'est de la politique fiction donc
on fait toujours fais attention de
telles hypothèses je suis un
scientifique donc hypothèse
expérimentation conclusion n'est-ce pas
et c'est évident que ce soit un autre
mode de scrutin les intentions de votre
changerait elle ne changerait pas
instantanément ça prendrait quelques
cycles mais ça changeait et là encore
une fois on voit le clivage entre
Montréal et le reste du Québec qui est
complètement séparé alors que si chaque
vote avait le même poids je veux dire
j'avais fait le test en regardant les
chiffres des circonscriptions si on
fusionnait bonne aventure et Gaspé en
une seule séquence il y a 24
circonscriptions du Grand Montréal qui
aurait une population plus grande que
cette nouvelle ça conscription là alors
évidemment le poids en vote des régions
est beaucoup plus importante que
Montréal sous informe format
proportionnelle évidemment les électeurs
auraient tous le même poids mais j'ai
fait l'exercice pour cette question là
parce que je l'ai vu venir donc Antoine
courchen qui veut savoir si on était en
mode de scrutin proportionnel à quoi
ressemblerait le résultat avec les
sondages actuels très bonne question je
répète politique fiction
on s'amuse mais avec les projections de
vote actuelle un mode de scooter
proportionnel avec un seuil de 5% donc
si en bas de 5% est partie n'a aucun
siège la CAC aurait 53 sièges en moyenne
donc ça prend 63 pour une majorité les
libéraux 26 Québec solidaires 17
conservateur 15 parties québécois 14 et
donc on aurait une carte minoritaire et
tous les partis d'opposition auraient la
balance du pouvoir alors est-ce qu'il y
aurait plus de collaboration peut-être
mais en termes de siège en terme de
support il y a il y aurait plusieurs
combinaisons possibles et je pense que
pour certaines électeurs c'est
intéressant mais je le répète c'est la
politique fiction il y aurait sûrement
beaucoup plus de parties si on avait une
professionnelle le paysage sera
différent à la ligne de départ même cela
dit on se retrouver avec un gouvernement
de la coalition de Québec qui pourrait
très facilement s'entendre avec le Parti
conservateur pour se faire une majorité
sur certaines choses et sur d'autres
peut-être ça serait un autre parti
deux ministères et puis ou bien une
entente comme celle qu'on voit Ottawa
est-ce que j'essaie de dire c'est que
les électeurs qui sont à gauche de la
coalition à venir Québec donc à gauche
je suis parti
conservateurs
du Québec Québec soldat et le PQ dont
j'ai hâte de voir comment il ferait pour
s'entendre ensemble pour former un
gouvernement
parce que leur différence sont beaucoup
plus irré-conilables et ça c'est ce que
le soi-disant ce terrain là gauche
jusqu'à centre droit donc est occupé par
trois parties qui sont pas capables
d'aller au même parti de Noël
c'est un pensif bien parce que les
apôtres de la proportionnelle ont
tendance à être des gens qui
s'identifient davantage à la gauche et
au centre gauche Canada droite alors
peut-être que ce serait une bonne idée
de regarder le fait que depuis le début
de la campagne plus que 50 % des gens
qui répondent au sondage sur les
intentions de vote pour la CAQ ou partie
consommateurs Michel Nicolas Gauthier de
Saint Bruno de Montarville veut savoir
étant donné que quatre parties
d'opposition nez à nez est-ce que ça
pourrait ramener sur le tapis l'idée de
reformer le mode de scrutinerie dans le
fond François Legault serait obligé de
reconsidérer ça puisqu'il va y avoir de
la pression après les élections
il va y avoir de la pression et c'est un
fait que le vainqueur du scrutin va être
le scrutin nominal à un tour
dans les fêtes vos garantir à la carte
une très bonne majorité si c'est pas une
super majorité oui il faut y penser en
même temps l'écueil a toujours été le
même les trois parties qui ont eu le
pouvoir de faire Révolution tranquille
le PQ des libéraux puis la carte ont
tous promis le scrutin proportionnel et
ils ont tous reculés à cause d'une chose
leur focus en voulait pas parce que les
gars disaient en tête perdre nos compter
par cause du développement personnel
puis des députés de liste des affaires
de mal alors à un moment donné si tu
peux pas le passer dans ton propre
caucus je pense pas que tu vas faire des
grandes réformes alors oui ça va revenir
sur le tapis c'est intéressant peut-être
pas des autobus mais certainement des
intellectuels et mais est-ce que est-ce
qu'ils vont bouger là-dessus moi je ne
le crois pas grand chose qui mérite une
bataille dans l'autobus 100 tout ça
comme ça là mais c'est rare qu'on se
boit dans les autobus
Michel et moi
ma prédiction on verra pas de système
proportionnelle
de moins qu'une proportionnelle et donc
même si c'est plus démocratique est-ce
que la discussion
et en plus je voudrais rapidement que le
mouvement classé nouvelle le plan qu'ils
avaient en 2018 était tout proche et
donc vous voulez faire une
proportionnelle arrivait quelque chose
de simple et élégant le système qu'ils
avaient choisi était vraiment majuster
vous dites 90 députés possible on verra
lundi mais Michel Dion se demande est-ce
que 90 92 93 députés c'est pas compliqué
pour François Legault à gérer en termes
de focus d'abord on a pas beaucoup de
clés de limousine à donner deuxièmement
à chaque fois qu'il y a une super
majorité ces dernières années c'est
Monsieur Boisset qui en a eu deux en 73
et
à sa première réélection à sa première
élection justement dans son deuxième
mandat les deux fois ils ont perdu
un moment donné les attentes sont trop
grandes aussi alors c'est c'est top et
l'autre chose c'est que ça va être un
deuxième mandat pour la claque aller
chercher un troisième ça c'est difficile
non mais moi un deuxième mandat qui a
été un mandat plus heureux que le
premier et là je parle pas simplement du
Québec puis je vous donne c'est ça
chaque année ajoute au poids de fatigue
et si on est pour être sur un décor de
succession en défactions plus
souverainiste et plus fédéraliste pas
fait cette période-là mais ça promet des
des belles journées Marylène vous êtes à
l'Assemblée nationale ça sera pas simple
à gérer
oui tout à fait on peut le penser parce
que oui effectivement Chantal le disait
il y a une frange un peu plus
souverainiste là tout le nom de Simon je
l'ai barréthme vient en tête celui de
Bernard drinville aussi et du côté
fédéraliste davantage Geneviève Guilbaud
on sait très bien
il y a certaines aspirent à mieux
apprendre justement la place de François
Legault alors ce sera pas ça même si
effectivement la réelle opposition sera
peut-être même dans son cocus parce
qu'il va y avoir des factions qui vont
nécessairement se disputer la première
place et on l'a vu pas eu beaucoup de
remaniement ministériels n'ont plus
durant un mandat de François Lebeau son
conseil des ministres plusieurs ont eu
le même ministère pendant quatre ans ce
qui est quand même assez rare ce que
forcer d'ailleurs la fonction publique a
travaillé davantage nous dit-on là parce
que un ministre qui a posé et qui avait
des exigences à la première année il y
en avait aussi à la deuxième à la
troisième et à la quatrième alors on
peut penser il y aura nécessairement
beaucoup de déçu si on atteint
effectivement le chiffre de 90 et plus
député c'est pas tout le monde
effectivement comme disait Michel qui
aura des limousines alors il y en aura
certains qui n'auront pas justement de
portefeuille qui seront assurément déçus
Chantal il y a deux chefs qui sont en
quête d'un siège de l'Assemblée
nationale pas saint-pierre-lamondon Éric
dumes est-ce que pour eux
c'est davantage important de gagner leur
siège ou d'avoir plus de votes en termes
de pourcentage de l'Assemblée nationale
c'est même pas un concours gagner un
siège c'est la chose la plus importante
chez cela parce que sans avoir la
tribune d'assemblée nationale c'est
extraordinairement difficile de réussir
à maintenir son pourcentage de vote je
prends que des rituels
on s'entend le mouvement
de réaction aux mesures sur la covid a
contribué à sa montée et là il pourra
pas surfer là-dessus pour garder son
parti à un niveau intéressant pendant
quatre ans sans avoir une courroie de
transmission qui serait lui à
l'Assemblée nationale pour se donner une
image plus large dans le cas du Parti
québécois ça le particulier
à l'Assemblée nationale peuvent pas se
permettre un autre mandat où il y a pas
de chef à l'Assemblée nationale alors on
a aussi il fallait qu'il choisisse entre
les deux et on leur demandera pas
c'est sûr que le choix à faire c'est je
veux être là parlez-en Maxime Bernier
à Monsieur dum de prendre son envol
c'est quand le fait qu'il ait
[Musique]
3 % de chance que ça pourrait changer
alors oui on regarde il y a des
circonscriptions dans le body fleuve la
Gaspésie entre le PQ et les
circonscription à Montréal
QS pourrait peut-être faire quelques
surprises on regarde l'esprit l'habitat
national la Beauce donc il y a quelques
pochettes de régions comme ça qui
pourraient être question d'Alexandre
Cadotte qui je pense vie à Québec
puisqu'il veut savoir dans Tachereau
est-ce que Québec solidaire va être en
mesure de garder sa circonscription
maintenant que Catherine Dorion a quitté
je serais extrêmement surpris si QS ne
parvient pas à garder ta chevaux les
autres parties n'ont pas mis énormément
d'énergie dans cette circonscription là
et c'est le type de clientèle la
démographie que Québec solidaire cherche
de toute façon Marie-Hélène le vote par
anticipation a été extrêmement populaire
c'est un record 24,5% des électeurs ont
déjà voté
et on sait que c'est important n'auront
pas voter on peut présumer que presque
une personne sur trois dans le fond déjà
voté est-ce que ça change la stratégie
des parties est-ce que dans le fond la
dernière semaine
un peu moins d'importance qu'elle
l'avait avant ce que vous avez remarqué
s'il y avait une différence étant donné
que le vote par anticipation est aussi
populaire plus ou moins François Legault
a une fin de campagne un peu à l'image
de celle de 2018 c'est à dire qu'il est
il se tient loin des grands centres fait
peu de mêler de presse aussi donc pour
limiter visiblement le risque d'erreur
du côté de Dominique Anglade on va quand
même on va quand même aller à coup de
joie c'est la première fois qu'un chef
se rend là-bas aux Îles de la Madeleine
alors que dans un cas comme dans l'autre
les libéraux ne sont pas dans le cou
et le pourtant fort à faire à Montréal
et à Laval du côté de Québec solidaire
on est plutôt en mode offensif c'est
intéressant de voir justement dans la
région de Montréal essentiellement même
danser Henri St-Jacques
circonscription de Dominique Anglade
alors et du côté du Parti québécois on
est dans l'est aujourd'hui c'était le
cas hier également parce qu'on veut
préserver nos acquis
il y a pas vraiment de eu de mouvement
disons ou de changement parce que c'est
sans conformité en fait avec les
sondages avec ce qu'on voit de toutes
les parties qui tirent davantage
d'un vote par anticipation aussi fort il
y en a que ça demande ce que ça va
favoriser un ça va faire favoriser
l'autre à quoi ça ressemble
Philippe le vote Parentis définitivement
la carte la carte il y a une domination
lorsqu'on découpe les sondages par
tranche d'âge les électeurs plus âgés de
façon disproportionnée de par rapport à
ce qu'on a vu dans les dernières
élections semble se ranger vers la CAQ
et le vote par anticipation bah ça fait
bien sûr c'est pour tout le monde il y a
beaucoup de personnes âgées donc c'est
ça qui est un avantage cap de ce côté-ci
je suis allé voter par une situation
[Rires]
j'osais pas le dire mais j'ai eu la même
expérience en passant je suis allé voir
le vote par anticipation en Ontario
c'était en juin 9% ah oui mais ça a pas
voté beaucoup à Ontario effectivement
il me reste il me reste une minute donc
ça va passer rapidement mais en quelques
secondes chacun vous surveillez quoi
précisément lundi Michel à quoi vous
allez être attentif je me demande si la
mauvaise performance des derniers jours
de monsieur Legault va jouer sur la
sortie de vote de la CAQ et ça ne peut
pas causer quelque chose c'est Philippe
nous on dirait
Marylène vous surveille quoi lundi on
surveille justement moi je
[Musique]
Québec 125 338 CANADA Merci beaucoup
bonne fin de campagne on se retrouve
dans les prochains jours merci Alex
merci beaucoup je prends quelques
secondes pour remercier mon équipe un
gros merci à l'équipe technique sur le
plateau W ici à la nouvelle Maison de
Radio-Canada la réalisation aussi pour
le facebook live merci d'avoir été à
l'écoute à la technique que
Charles-Antoine Lemay Martin
Vaillancourt Martin Lavoie à la
recherche cette semaine dépendamment de
la journée en rotation Karine
Guillemette Geneviève gagné mais dit à
la Wii et Marc Herrero Dufour et Yohan d
Vincent notre journaliste est Annick
Béraud à la réalisation c'est de Dimitri
kata d'autiste notre rédactrice en chef
et Maryse Gagnon je vous dis à lundi
bonne fin de semaine à très bientôt
[Musique]